Impeachment is the word of the day.
The first step of the impeachment process
of Donald Trump has started, and Donald Trump
is flying off the rails.
As a result, we will talk about all of this.
This is an impeachment inquiry, important
word.
A lot of people have very clearly not understanding
the full process, and why would you, impeachment
of presidents is not a common thing.
This was announced yesterday by the speaker
of the house, Nancy Pelosi.
Let's take a look.
The actions of the Trump presidency revealed
dishonorable fact of the president's betrayal
of his oath of office, betrayal of our national
security and betrayal of the integrity of
our elections.
Therefore, today I'm announcing the house
of representatives moving forward with an
official impeachment inquiry.
I'm directing our six committees to proceed
with their investigations under that umbrella.
So
there's confusion about what this is and what
this is not.
Impeachment is a long process.
There are three primary steps, and these can
be subdivided into even really 10 or 12 different
steps, but the generality, the three primary
phases are an impeachment inquiry.
If the inquiry leads the inquirers to decide
that actually impeaching the president via
a trial is appropriate.
You go to an impeachment trial by the house
of representatives and after that phase is
complete, phase two, you go to phase three,
which is a vote in the Senate as to whether
or not to convict the president and thus remove
them from office.
Now, this is not going to lead to a conviction
of Donald Trump in the Senate, and thus the
removal of Donald Trump.
The Senate is controlled by Republicans.
We don't have to go through the details, but
as you know, if you've been following politics
for the last couple of years with some very
limited exceptions, Republicans are not interested,
willing, or even remotely considering removing
this president from office.
So the process that Democrats will now follow
must be strategic and it must be thought out
because Donald Trump will try and he is already
trying.
You will see his tweets momentarily to turn
this around into, he's the victim.
He's a martyr, just doing great things for
the United States and these witch hunt Democrats
won't let him just make America great again.
So this, the, the goal here is hurt Trump
in 2020 because the impeachment process is
not going to remove Donald Trump.
So that then becomes a question of, are we
confident that Democrats can carry this out
in the right way?
Is there going to be in fighting among Democrats
around this such that it will become a distraction?
We already saw there's this, a, a member of
Congress from Hawaii who was running for president
named Tulsi Gabbert.
She says, she's against what Nancy Pelosi
is doing.
Are we going to see conflict within the democratic
party that will allow Donald Trump to take
advantage of this in some way?
Uh, last night on I did a live stream on YouTube,
uh, about the breaking impeachment news.
And there were a lot of people who were saying,
David, you know this talk of impeachment backfiring.
That's a Republican talking point.
No, no, no.
I'm not talking about the process backfiring
in so far as the impeachment inquiry is not
warranted on the substance.
Donald Trump clearly deserves, at minimum
an impeachment inquiry will not put the cart
before the horse.
Depending on what the inquiry finds, we can
talk about whether the impeachment trial is
the next step.
That's not what I mean when I say backfire.
What I mean by backfire is that if Democrats
bungled the process, if Democrats bungled
the PR around this, it will allow Donald Trump
to paint himself successfully as the victim
martyr.
And it will not hurt him.
In 2020 I've been getting emails from people
saying, David, it's over for Trump.
Trump needs to resign and set up Mike [inaudible],
Mike Pence to pardon him the way that Richard
Nixon did.
Number one, it's unlikely that Donald Trump's
ego would allow that to happen, but I don't
think it's necessary.
Donald Trump is not going to be convicted
on impeachment by a Republican controlled
Senate before January of 2021, which is when
the next, um, uh, Congress and president would
be sworn in.
So there are two ways that this can go given
that Trump won't be removed before the election.
Number one, this doesn't work because Americans
get exhausted by 14 months of it or however
many months, I guess for 13 months leading
up to the election and it ends up helping
Donald Trump.
That's one way.
The other way it can go is that the inquiry
reveals the president's wrongdoing in such
a, an uh, an uncontestable way, a to such
a degree that it destroys Trump and Republicans
in the 2020 election.
When we go back to bill Clinton, people like
to remind me that bill Clinton's approval
went up during impeachment.
But remember number one, bill Clinton didn't
try to interfere.
Number two, bill Clinton had a strong economy
and number three, what was at issue were lies
about an affair.
Donald Trump has engaged in borderline trader
his behavior and of course Donald Trump is
absolutely losing it on Twitter, which is
an indication that he is not going to allow
this process to play out calmly in the way
that bill Clinton did.
I've been telling you for years, if impeachment
starts, what we've seen on Twitter so far
by Donald Trump will be nothing compared to
what we will see.
And it's already happening.
Donald Trump starting to wind up yesterday
tweeting such an important day at the United
nations.
So much work and so much success.
And the Democrats purposely had to ruin and
demean it with more breaking news, which hunt
garbage so bad for our country.
Later tweeting presidential harassment in
all caps.
And then this morning scaling it up even more.
Donald Trump tweeting quote, there has been
no president in the history of our Capitol
C country who has been treated so badly as
I have.
The Democrats are frozen with hatred and fear.
They get nothing done.
This should never be allowed to happen to
another president, which hunt.
So remember, Trump won't be removed by this
impeachment because once again, Republicans
control the Senate.
But Donald Trump is already losing it.
If there were to be, I mean, listen, imagine
if Donald Trump were to be convicted and removed
by the Senate.
Imagine the level of violence that we would
see happening from Trumpists.
Uh, I, I would actually consider staying away
from public places.
I really would.
But in the end, that's not going to happen.
And the conversation has been about is the
president going to be removed and what is
the strategy on that basis?
The real question is should the president
be impeached given what we know?
And the answer is as far as an impeachment
inquiry, obviously yes.
So this inquiry is the first step and it is
the correct step.
There is no question about it.
The political strategy around it is important
given that the Senate is not going to vote
to convict, but on the facts, obviously there
is a, a completely, uh, there's a completely
obvious case for why this impeachment inquiry
is now starting.
And it's not only Donald Trump who's flipping
out, it's also Rudy Giuliani.
Let's talk about that next.